estallidos en zonas controladas por
Rusia las autoridades ucranianas
reportaron que explotó un carro bomba en
melitopol una ciudad ubicada en la
región de zaporilla según keff otras
siete explosiones ocurrieron durante la
noche mientras en la región de luans que
ejerzon el kremlin repele ataques de la
contraofensiva ucraniana la copia el
fuego de la artillería rusa derrotó a
las unidades de las fuerzas armadas
ucranianas como resultado el enemigo fue
expulsado a sus posiciones originales en
el sector de nikolaive el enemigo
utilizando dos grupos tácticos atacó sin
éxito las posiciones de nuestras
tropasón las evacuaciones de civiles a
través del río de nípro continúan a los
que llegan a territorio ruso se les
darán viviendas temporales y asistencia
médica
Los residentes serán alojados en 10
puntos de alojamiento temporal en
instituciones sanitarias de la región de
krasnodar
representantes del Ministerio de
emergencia de Rusia junto con los
voluntarios están ayudando a los
residentes a enviarlos a los puntos de
alojamiento temporal
de forma paralela en Berlín avanza la
conferencia internacional de expertos
para la reconstrucción de Ucrania el
canciller Alemán olafcholes insistió en
la necesidad de invertir entre 3.000 y
5000 millones de euros en Ucrania a
partir de enero debido la reconstrucción
de su país era una tarea generacional
ningún país ningún donante ninguna
institución internacional puede hacerlo
solo por ello Es aún más importante que
fijemos juntos el rumbo ahora para que
la reconstrucción tenga éxito
el presidente ucraniano bolodimir
selensky pidió invertir cuanto antes en
esta reconstrucción que según fonder
Legend no puede esperar hasta el final
de la guerra